[Applaudissements]
j'irai m'asseoir et ludique qu'on soit à
oui bonsoir oui bonsoir en gastambide on
s'habitue
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai au studio d'à côté non tu
t'étais pas à excuse moi tu es venu en
chine traîneau anwar khan en mars qu'il
verrait la fiche qui n'arrive pas aussi
merde
excuse moi j'étais venu pour me cacher
les parce que on est on est pas te tu
vois c'est vrai que j'étais son
téléphone et là tu me cherche des poux
dans la tête c'est facile à tous et ce
qui est vrai c'est qu'il était il a
hésité un moment c'est pas dit c'est
maintenant jean la lentille rogers de
clients la gto pa et va nous répondre
j'ai la réponse de franck qu'est-ce
qu'il dit regardez vous avez à dire vous
même jamais de la vie et non non mais tu
connais ludovic non bien sûr que non
ludovic si et quand par exemple
ben en 2003 quand j'ai quand j'étais
avec toi sur le
il est venu me dire pendant la pub on
travaille ou galère le bon mec a même
[Rires]
tourné le texte vous verrez de voir que
ton ami franck en fait il n'y pas tout
qu'est ce qui se passe à y [ __ ] il
faut que ça cesse 1 tout le monde me
parle du caire
et alors dg john des places aux jeunes
des places pour dire à la france entière
évidemment il n'y aura pas à matthieu
delormeau chaleureusement et mais je
suis venu avec un petit cadeau pour toi
c'est l'équipe de taxi qui t'offre ce
canot qui te correspond